tamson tell me about your character you
play molly in this film don't you yes
she is the birth mother of Estella quite
integral to the story but a tiny role
and it was just a really great fun to
work with ray Fiennes did most of my
stuff with Robbie Coltrane and yes she's
a feisty chick and probably had quite a
hard life but now is the housekeeper for
Jagger's and most of my stuff I think I
was quite in order of the director and
the actors around me but I still managed
to pull it off I think I haven't seen
the film saucy she's a great role you
say she is so important to the story her
character and what she brings to how she
affects the other characters you know
how did you have to kind of psych
yourself up well it's quite high intense
drama coming in at quite a level so I
suppose I just separated myself and the
the tears were all quite real and I
remember feeling quite pent up and and
Mike was just brilliant when when we
finished he's a great well done and I
just thought that it should I do it
again but yeah I loved it had a great
time we look forward to next all sorts
as a few bits and pieces I think I'm
doing a doctor who soon a plan coming up
soon I've still got a ten week old baby
at home so getting home to her tonight
will be quite a big deal for me he tell
us a little bit about Doctor Who I can't
really know all I know is I think it's
happening do you think you'll be a good
year a baddie which would you rather be
I like to play a baddie but I haven't
done a good you for a while so it'll be
nice to play goody
you